we're in shap LeMay 70 kilometers away
from Togo's capsule lawmen dr. Michelle
Kadam is one of the few doctors who
comes by regularly the checkup is free
his nickname here the poor man's doctor
we're trying to treat these students for
all possible parasites and to check that
they are healthy for the start of the
new term Chris : dr. Kadam founded the
organisation Emma fleek ten years ago
his goal providing health care for all
if we didn't make the effort we wouldn't
be able to reach these people that's the
biggest problem did you see how long it
took to reach the village so it's a
problem of mobilizing the resources shap
LeMay doesn't have a health centre just
a public school cor Dom's regular visits
are the only health service the 1,500
villagers get today is accompanied by a
representative from the Ministry of
Health togo's government is unable to
pay the doctor so Kadam uses every
occasion to call for donations the
Ministry representative is impressed by
his work I don't even have the words to
describe this it's an extraordinary
effort the next morning Kadam is back in
law men not even the capital has a
well-functioning health care system in
his private clinic the doctor sees
patients who can pay for their treatment
the idea those who can afford it should
also pay more he uses the money he earns
to finance his trips to the villagers a
miniatures solidarity system with code
on at the centre
we always tell ourselves it's great to
treat the patients who have insurance
and the money to pay us but it's also
important to think of those who don't
have the means to visit a clinic and get
treatment but the money is not enough to
provide medical care for Togo's entire
rural population we unfortunately don't
get any support from the state we have
to ask for donations for each and every
trip with us the philosophy of
materialism and we still haven't got
enough for the next trip in one or two
months previously but we won't give up
Michele Kadam and his helpers have
treated over 300,000 people in Togo in
the past ten years is even taken his
mission beyond togo's borders the NGO am
a freak now operates in six other West
African countries